from calorie counts to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Subway in the US and in China
this is food Wars
here in China standard Subway subs come
in two sizes
six inch and
12 inch
they've done us the favor of cutting our
12 inch sub in half
very kind in the US our subs also come
in two sizes a six inch or a 12 inch
also known as the footlong we're going
to measure both of these with a tape
measure to make sure that those lengths
are actually correct what does it look
like is it right is it good
I would say it's like maybe a few
centimeters off of 12 inches but it's
close enough like I don't think you're
going to notice a few centimeters of
Sandwich missing I'll give you a pass
Subway that's that's fine
about
30.8 centimeters
12.12598 inches that one is six inches
for sure about 15 centimeters
5.9055 inches we can also get sub
platters in the US ours are the exact
same size five 12 inch subs cut into 15
pieces that is a lot of sandwich it's
very very heavy it's really heavy
I'm gonna leave it there we used to have
sub platters and party Subs but shows
over folks no more parties on this side
of the Pacific how's it look for you
Nico we used to have party Subs in the
US but Subway overhauled and streamlined
its menu last year and now seems to have
stopped offering them somebody check on
Joe right now because I know he is
devastated
moving on from Subs drinks at a Chinese
Subway only come in one size medium
drinks at a U.S Subway come in four
sizes small 21 ounces medium 30 ounces
or large which is 40 ounces you may have
noticed I said we have four drink sizes
that only showed you three that's
because on Subway's catering menu in the
US you'll find this
thank you to my beautiful assistant it's
a gallon of Hubert's lemonade this
supposedly serves eight people which
would be 16 fluid ounces each why is the
recommended serving size for this
lemonade smaller than the usual small
size that's very suspicious Subway but I
do love this lemonade so the large is
supposed to be 40 ounces we're gonna
measure it to see if I'm being lied to
basically the medium is meant to contain
473 milliliters of your drink let's see
how much is actually in there the coke
is really dark so it's kind of hard for
me to see the numbers but it did go
slightly above 32 ounces which is
significantly less than the 40 I was
promised and by the way this was with no
ice it's meant to be 473 milliliters but
I just wanted to show you look how much
is missing from the top this here is
about
425 ish and if that's the case it's
missing over 50 milliliters of my soda
what give Subway
[Music]
here's everything that you'll find at
Subway China that you won't find in the
US here's everything that you'll find at
a U.S Subway that you won't find in
China obviously Subway's menu is highly
customizable by combining different
ingredients Subway claims you can create
over 2 million sandwiches
I don't know if I believe that but I
also don't have the time and or money to
prove it so let's just say it's true now
let's start with the foundation of any
sandwich the bread now here in China we
have a couple of options and by a couple
I mean two that you don't have in the US
first is honey oat and the second is
Parmesan oregano now it's on the menu
but of all of the stores that we ordered
from they all changed out the Parmesan
oregano for just regular bread so I
don't know if they're offering it
anymore or it's just still on the menu
and they've forgotten to take it out and
in the US we also have exclusive bread
options like Artisan Flatbread and
Hearty multigrain once you've picked
your bread then it's time to choose your
fillings these are all of China's
exclusive fillings that you won't find
in the US starting with the black pepper
thick cut steak oh they weren't joking
when they said thick cut
I know
that's pretty decent here we have the
Italian sausage and
the chicken thigh chop it's always the
chicken thigh when it comes to chicken
meat in a burger because Chinese
people's thigh is the juicy part not the
breast next we've got the egg Mayo
series we love our egg Mayo here we've
got salami egg Mayo I will need to ask
for more salami next time four pieces
just doesn't cut it when you've got a
six inch sub there's also the tuna egg
Mayo I'm just gonna move swiftly onto
the chicken teriyaki egg Mayo the
Chinese name is quite descriptive it's
it's the parent and child sandwich
because obviously chicken and egg
put egg Mayo in a bun I'm happy here
we've got the teriyaki chicken sandwich
on honey oat bread it's not got egg Mayo
in it it's an inferior teriyaki chicken
the Full House which is tuna and chicken
oh it's a good thing none of you can
smell my breath right now
and here we've just got the bog standard
ham Save The Best For Last our pulled
pork limited edition sandwich with Chia
seeds in our bread I'm quite pleased
with the amount of meat that's found its
way into the Subway subs
a little bit too sweet for my taste
but the pulled pork is there we have a
ton of Subs in the U.S that aren't on
the Chinese menu so let's start with the
classic sandwiches so we've got the big
hop pastrami buffalo chicken chicken and
bacon ranch cold cut combo meatball
marinara oven roasted turkey and ham
steak and cheese and the veggie patty a
fast food meatball sub sounds difficult
so I kind of want to try it and see how
it tastes this is a very heavy sandwich
I just want to say it reminds me of
school lunch like the smell of walking
into a cafeteria when you're in like
seventh grade that's the vibe I'm
getting from it
it's an okay meatball sub so this is the
chicken bacon ranch I love chicken I
love bacon and I love ranch so hopefully
I like this sandwich there's just
something about how the meat looks
that's making my tummy hurt a little I
think it's just the paleness of the
chicken and bread
I mean it tastes better than it looks
next we have the no bready balls
starting with the black pepper steak egg
Mayo no bready bowl this actually looks
really good they've got some kidney
beans and some kind of coarse grain at
the bottom as well this actually looks
decent I am now this tastes really good
next we have the tuna egg Mayo no bready
bowl oh that does not look appetizing
the teriyaki chicken egg Mayo no bready
bowl but this is actually pretty decent
I think the no bready balls are probably
actually order again we also have the no
bready bowls which according to the menu
are different than a salad although they
look exactly like a salad a salad hidden
under a mountain of deli meats here are
all of the Us exclusive bready Bowls the
exclusive sandwiches don't stop there in
2022 Subway in the US launched a range
of menu items known as the subway series
it's a list of 12 Subs with
predetermined ingredients designed to
streamline the ordering process so
instead of going down the line and
picking every individual thing that you
want you can just order these off a menu
while prepping for this shoot we thought
we had most of the subs on the subway
series menu but since then we have found
out that they have dropped more
sandwiches on this menu the list just
seems to keep growing and I don't know
when they're gonna stop so let's just
focus on the subs that we have in front
of us right now I am very intrigued by
the monster that name sounds awful and
I'm hoping the sandwich will not be I
think it looks pretty good to me okay so
this is the monster which is steak bacon
and cheddar
that's delicious it's good the Bella
matzah I think that if I was any of the
sandwiches on this list I would want to
be this one because why wouldn't I want
to be the prettiest sandwich this one
definitely has like a more pleasing look
to it there's just like so much color in
it it looks like it has a lot of fresh
ingredients in it so in the Bella Mata
we have ham capicola and mozzarella all
delicious let's taste it
oh um
and I really really like it this feels
very classic sandwich to me like if I
was going to a sandwich shop I'd
probably order something like this so
This Is The All-American which has
turkey ham and bacon she looks pretty
good
she's not really giving I think it's too
much onions I really really want to
taste the sliced Avo Mexicali this one
has rotisserie chicken avocado and
pepper jack that all sounds so good to
me oh she's saucy
I feel like I haven't seen much sauce
going on so this is different there's a
lot of sauce in there
it's good but I think the sandwich has
just been sitting here for so long that
the bread got soggy so the bread on the
bottom is like very very soft
but the actual Taste of the sandwich is
really really good it's honestly tasty
and Subway also offers wraps so here
we've got their black pepper steak wrap
oh yeah I think I prefer this version
next we have the teriyaki chicken wrap
smells a bit wet the turkey breast wrap
there's literally one slice of turkey
breast here we have the Italian sausage
wrap the sausage has been butterflied
it's just one sausage it's actually okay
after doing all of this Subway research
they actually added wraps onto our menu
here are all of the wraps that you can
get on the US menu
we also have a couple of exclusive meat
options in the U.S pepperoni and
capicola here in China we have some
meaty toppings that you won't find in
the US for example
shrimp which
they literally gave us in a paper bag so
we will ask you if you want cheese on
your sub and we definitely have a lot
more cheese options than they have in
China both countries offer American or
shredded mozzarella but the U.S also
offers pepper jack provolone Swiss or
Monterey cheddar China has one sandwich
topping that you won't find in the U.S
and that's egg Mayo we love eggmo here I
love egg Mayo it's basically just chunky
Mayo with eggs inside and you'll find it
in over half of our offerings here in
China Subway you have it in Subs you
have it in wraps and you have it in
protein bowls as well all of these are
egg Mayo it's delicious when it comes to
vegetable toppings both the U.S and
China offer tomatoes lettuce cucumber
pickles green pepper black olives red
onions and jalapenos but the U.S also
carries banana peppers my favorite
spinach and avocado we also have some
exclusive sauces like barbecue and
thousand island dressing and then
there's also Mayo honey mustard black
pepper sauce and olive oil it's kind of
shocking that we don't have thousand
island dressing as an option it's not
like a super common sandwich spread at
least not in my house but you do see it
on Reubens and stuff like that exclusive
sauces in the U.S include oil red wine
vinegar creamy Sriracha buffalo sauce
MVP parmesan vinaigrette and roasted
garlic aioli
they shove these words in everywhere you
guys are like trying to Gaslight me into
thinking that this is like an athlete's
favorite food and I know that's not true
it's crazy it's crazy What's Happening
Here MVP parmesan vinaigrette isn't real
you made that up speaking of trying to
make me think that athletes love Subway
here are the athlete collabs here we
have the avocado Spike bowl by Rob
Gronkowski the no look chicken by
Patrick Mahomes the front Court Feast by
Charles Barkley the meatball Marksman by
Steph Curry and then there's the danger
witch
let's talk about the danger witch Once
Upon a Time this was Russell Wilson's
Subway collab sandwich I don't know what
happened but at some point they removed
his name from the sandwich I think it
has something to do with this weird
commercial they did promoting the danger
witch you ever done anything dangerous
I obviously can't confirm anything but
I'm dying to try this so let's see what
the danger witch tastes like
they probably should get rid of it in
general because it's also just not a
very good sandwich it mostly just tastes
like mustard now it's tradition on food
Wars to combine all of one country's
exclusives together I present to you the
us only sub
it has bacon pepper jack cheese banana
peppers spinach buffalo sauce all on
jalapeno cheddar bread I think our
specific Subway didn't have jalapeno
cheddar bread this is their other cheesy
bread but it's the closest thing we got
it mostly just tastes like bacon which
I'm not upset about this is the China
only sub black pepper steak
egg Mayo
Thousand Island dressing
on honey oat bread let's see if you guys
in the states are missing out you know
egmail goes on absolutely anything
and the
thick cut steak
gives it a nice bump yeah I'd order this
again now let's see what side options we
have in the U.S chips in general seem to
be more of a U.S exclusive here are all
of the flavors I was able to get my
hands on at our location so we have
three lace flavors there's sour cream
and onion plastic and barbecue
we also have two baked glaze flavors the
original and barbecue we have Doritos in
both cool ranch and nacho cheese two
flavors of Miss Vicki's chips we have
jalapeno and spicy dill pickle and we
have three flavors of Sun Chips we have
garden salsa original and harvest
cheddar you can also get a go go squeeze
applesauce as a kids side Subway also
has sides namely ratan pepper popcorn
chicken so I would assume that this is
meant to be sutrani Style Chicken in
that it should be spicy and also make
your mouth pleasantly numb
just the tiniest hint of chili heat here
we've got some potato balls
it just tastes like hash browns now this
is pretty unique this is called western
region style roast chicken wings usually
when you say something is western region
flavored they usually mean lamb or cumin
no that's pretty good no potato chips
here we're super healthy but we do have
cookies now both the US and China each
have an exclusive cookie here in China
we have the
Peach oolong
hmm
that's quite Pleasant and Subway in the
U.S offers the raspberry cheesecake
cookie I love Subway cookies they are
surprisingly soft and definitely the
best cookie in fast food in my opinion I
just think that they're so good
it's amazing as I suspected and finally
we have drinks I am very happy that
Subways in the U.S carry Coke products
you can get a classic Coca-Cola a little
DC Sprite Dasani which
my favorite Vitamin Water triple X Gold
Peak sweet tea simply lemonade orange or
apple Honest Kids Superfruit Punch or a
hubris lemonade for drinks China carries
soy milk and PepsiCo products so you can
get Pepsi Pepsi light 7Up Tropicana you
can also get Aquafina water and it's
soda water variety but I guess only in
select sauce because when we ordered we
ended up getting non-full spring which
is kind of like the Chinese version of
Evian I would say now Subway entered
China relatively late in 2005 and I
believe Nationwide they've got about 700
stores when they first opened they had a
lot more presents than they do now
they've kind of slid Into Obscurity and
they're only really found in major
cities like Beijing and Shanghai
sandwiches aren't really hot in China
people don't like cold bread cold
sandwiches of course you can ask for
your sandwich too heated up but just the
fact that it's kind of a
cold sandwich as a default is a bit of a
turn off I think you can tell there
hasn't been much localization on the
Subway menu I mean there's the egg Mayo
there's the western region chicken but
cold custom-made sandwiches are not
really the first thing you think of when
you want food in China you can probably
guess that Subway is in a bit of a sad
State here in China in terms of
competition I mean there's no need to
even try to compete with KFC McAdoo
they're so far ahead completely left
Subway in the dust
getting their subs for Less a foot long
Italian BMT from a Chinese Subway costs
47 Yen that's 6.79 at the time of
recording a footlong Italian BMT from a
U.S Subway costs 9.99 I was so curious
as to what BMT means and it apparently
stands for biggest meatiest tastiest
I don't know if I like that that makes
the U.S sandwich this much more
expensive Subway pricing has been a
contentious subject in the US for a
while now you guys might remember the
infamous Five Dollar Foot long promotion
Subway operated for a really long time
it was pulled after franchisee said it
was costing them too much money Subway
has repeatedly attempted to bring it
back but it's been quickly killed every
single time
foreign I have a feeling that U.S Subway
will be more unhealthy than China's
Subway so let's compare a classic turkey
sub a six inch oven roasted turkey sub
in the U.S is 270 calories now Subway
China hasn't released its nutritional
information but based on Independent
third-party research I can tell you that
a six inch oven roasted turkey sub here
in China is
252 calories
or 270 depending on who you talk to the
most calorific sandwich you can get is
the chicken and bacon ranch which clocks
in at 570 calories I want to guess the
most caloric sandwich in Subway China I
think it has to be the black pepper
thick cut steak am I right close a six
inch black pepper thick cut is 415
calories but our heaviest hitter is in
fact the six inch tuna sandwich clocking
in at 450 calories not only is it not
tasty it's also incredibly colorific the
no-look chicken by Austin Mahomes
Mahomes is it not Mahomes
Austin Mahone is a singer and I
literally changed his his name is fat
you guys imagine if that went up